I want to know what formulas causes
people to stop having kids and for
people to have more kids more kids lack
of education does that equal more kids
lack of
um you know entertainment and
advancement and technology is that what
causes more kids is it cultural
expectation of hey in our community in
our religion you can have as many kids
as you want five six seven eight kids
what is it okay and then like the the
number that we have that's 2.1 I like
that because we have a number to go off
of that were at least grown our
population I'm more interested to see
what trends do we notice with some
countries that are growing and declining
what is it why is that happening I
really I really do think in the Muslim
nations in the Quran it does say
children are a gift from God and they
just and I know Muslim guys that have I
know a guy one of my boys has five kids
and their attitude is just flood the
world as much as us as we can so so
we'll be we'll be a voice to be heard
and I mean dude it's I mean it's
happening the majority of Muslim men
that I know have at least three kids at
least average and the same I believe in
Judaism the the insistence that children
are a blessing now so I don't have the
formula what I can tell you and what we
address in the book is that
in the west we are embracing the
anti-formula not that children are a
blessing
from God higher power whatever but the
children are a curse upon the world that
humanity is a cancer upon the world that
to bring a child into the world is an
act of ultimate selfishness let's say
that you are young and impressionable uh
young person uh reading the New York
Times Washington Post or the Atlantic
what are the stories that you would have
encountered over the last six months
um having children is selfish children
will consume or will produce more CO2
into the atmosphere in general lifetime
than five trucks or whatever
um and and what we found was that
actually public opinion polls are
beginning to reflect this kind of
apocalyptic vision of the future where
increasing numbers of men and women
around the world but primarily in the
West
are saying we cannot bring a child into
the world because the world is going to
end famously AOC sites four years ago
yeah and in 12.
um that the world is getting worse which
is an another falsehood now it doesn't
mean that the world doesn't have
problems the world has God knows how
many problems but compared to when when
you compared us to 20 50 200 years ago
the world is in much better shape yet
somehow people have this notion that the
world is getting worse it is going to
end we are going to run out of resources
we are going to despoil the planet the
plan is going to explode everything and
and and and so increasingly people are
saying we cannot bring a child into the
world that is about to end and so the
point that I mean you think people are
thinking about that well they say so
explicitly it's it's in the book we
point to
opinion polls that show that people
really believe that we are heading
towards some sort of a planetary
catastrophe
so Mary what do you tell those people
that are saying because like right now I
think we're at seven billion 900
000 and and growing when it comes we
crossed eight billion in November of
last year okay officially I think I
didn't get the email of the balloon
whatever so but hey Mary what do you
tell these people that are uh they're
concerned about all the natural
resources that that we do have so are
you saying with that growth comes all
the stuff like you know the fake meat
that they're making you know eat bugs
like are you saying that there's enough
natural resources here that will we
could flourish no matter how high this
number is gonna get
oh absolutely
um there is plenty to go around and uh
when shortages do occur within the
market uh mechanism you can always
produce more we produce much more wheat
per acre of land than our ancestors
could that is why we are able to feed
eight billion people around the world
have you noticed that in spite of all of
this population growth so again let's
start with the numbers 1800 Thomas
Jefferson is president of the United
States there is one billion people in
the world today uh Biden is president
for veteran For Worse there is eight
billion people in the world and yet we
are able to feed on all of these people
and actually we are beginning to take
some of the land which we used for
agriculture and we are beginning to
return it to Nature to animals and to
Flora how do we do that we increase
weight production or yield on one acre
of land this is how you do it
if you're running out of fish we are
currently running out of fish in the
wild much of many of much of the ocean
is becoming depopulated of fish what do
you do you turn to aquaculture you start
breeding fish in ponds 50 of all of our
fish consumption now is
uh
fish grown specifically for the purpose
of being eaten so we don't catch them in
the wild and hopefully we can get to 100
should at some point in the future
should it happen that I don't know we
are going to somehow run out of cattle
or chicken well we are just going to
grow cells of chicken or or beef in in
huge bots
of of um of liquid and we are going to
produce food that way it's not going to
be it's not going to be impossible food
this is actually going to you'll be
eating a steak actual steak yeah it just
happened to be grown from a cell of
probably a fantastic cow yeah so all of
those listeners out there who always
wanted to eat a while ago steak but
cannot afford it because it's it costs
300 one day we'll be able to take the
jeans or the or the cells from the best
cows in the world maybe the ones from
Japan and everybody will have a steak
for five or ten dollars you can't wait
so so that's what I'm saying is that is
that is that the the amount of resources
in the world is only subject to human
knowledge it's human knowledge that
matters because we can always create
more we can grow more is your contention
that
with population growth you know we're at
8 billion we were at 1 billion in 1800
years ago plus that the more people the
more Minds there are that's a more
technological advancements will come of
it the more you know you get smarter
more efficient more innovative
and better things will happen because
there's more people not despite it that
that is the fundamental premise of the
book so you the the thing to to remember
is that not everybody can be an inventor
or an innovator only a small fraction of
humans will ever invent or innovate
anything it's it's in single digits it's
probably around five or six percent but
everyone reaps the benefits of those
Innovations
precisely I mean I wish to God that we
could have eight billion own muscles
that the world would look very different
but we don't but by but my point is that
six percent out of population of 300
million people who lived at the time of
Christ or Caesar Augustus really the
world's population was 300 million or or
six percent of one billion people who
lived at a time of Jefferson is still
much smaller total number than if you
have a population of 8 billion people so
if that fraction of humans who innovate
stays the same
then obviously you're going to have many
more people like that in a population of
8 billion and and it is these people who
have it's only human mind currently that
can produce new ideas it is new ideas
that you can turn into inventions then
those inventions get tested in the
marketplace to separate bad inventions
from good inventions the VHS from uh
betamax you know
um uh and the the diet coke from Crystal
Coke or whatever it was called I can't
remember that uh the traband from a
Ferrari and and and you will end up
basically with innovations that increase
productivity human productivity and
therefore our standards of living I want
to go back to what Pat sort of
questioned you on was uh about whether
or not whether it's the media whether
it's politicians whoever it is
mainstream media that is trying to
convince people not to have kids what I
want to kind of hone in on is America
and Western civilizations
I want to know what percentage is white
college educated women who are basically
saying I'm done with having kids on this
dream of being a a mother a housewife a
homemaker is it's not for me I just want
to work and make money and then that is
leading to sort of population decline
can you hone in on that so I don't know
the numbers because the studies that I
have seen the public opinion posts have
not been broken down by race or
political
political persuasion
but
just go with your gutter no but what I
can tell you what I can tell you is that
the Richer the society becomes the the
higher you go up the uh Maslow hierarchy
of needs you know at the bottom you have
your clothing your food your water your
security and at the top you have
self-actualization and basically what
tends to happen is that it is in
societies where people are extremely
rich and again we are extremely rich by
historical standards where people have
all this time and all this money to
basically devote themselves to pet
projects such as
um I don't know I I want to live in the
United States where all the plastic is
banned or I want to transform the United
States into
a society where uh that there are no
guns or where there are abortions and
things like that the the point is people
have all this time and all of these
resources to to pursue their pet project
now the Pet Project can be good the Pet
Project can be bad but it's only rich
people who have this who have this
amount of time to do that yeah can you
pull up uh Maslow's a hierarchy of needs
hierarchy of needs so yeah it's very
interesting because I want to I want to
get your opinion on essentially what you
said I interviewed this you remember the
freedom Forum it's about Gary Kasparov
yes yes okay so I was invited there via
Pat Uh a year and a half ago and
um
I interviewed who is essentially I
forgive me I forgot his name he
basically hosts The Daily Show but of
Iraq oh really he's a comedian humorous
satire uh and I said what's your biggest
wish
for the people of Iraq and you know you
would assume you know living under no
fear and tyrannical governments and he
says my wish is for them to just come
home every night and watch reality TV
and that be the biggest thing on their
mind I said why what are you talking
about he says do you understand how
lucky you are in America to go to your
job to work to just live your life do
what you want to do and come home and
have the freedom to just watch
meaningless dribble on TV because you're
not concerned that a bomb is coming over
your head that someone in your family is
going to get dragged out of the house
for having dissenting political views
and just you're not you know scraping by
for food Water Shelter any of the basic
human needs on the Maslow's hierarchy of
needs and he goes my wish is for the
people of Iraq to just watch the
Kardashians mind-numbingly mindless yeah
but he goes unfortunately we can't do
that life's tough and that was such a
stark example of like holy [__] that's
how where we're at in America today we
have life is so easy it's so good that
our biggest issue is like whether Chloe
lost four pounds today on the
Kardashians pregnant or not or Rihanna's
whatever it is and it just things are so
good here in the West in America that it
it's almost manifesting like things are
so bad because we have so much time to
focus on minor things that don't affect
day-to-day life yeah is that essentially
your premise yes and and it gets a
little bit worse than that and in a
sense that you see at the top of the
pyramid things are only Zero Sum
um at the bottom of the pyramid if you
have freedom if you have people they are
going to provide for water food shelter
through normal Market mechanism right uh
we have sort of tackled that particular
that level at the mass of the Maslow
pyramid pyramid of needs
um back in maybe like the 40s or the 50s
um
but again the market can provide more
food more shelter more sleep Innovation
growth Etc but at the top of the pyramid
the problem with self-actualization
where it becomes zero sum is that your
idea what a perfect Society may be may
may be in direct conflict with mine yeah
so maybe you're prioritizing uh equality
uh of outcome over my prioritization of
Liberty and the ability to succeed or
fail within the market system and so
when when we are at the top of the
pyramid and you insist that everybody
should have equality of outcome that
affects me negatively immediately
because it means that I have to forego
something if I'm better off than you are
and that's what leads to social conflict
I think that's part of the reason why we
are at each other's throats is because
we are all at the top of the pyramid but
we have very different ideas about how
the world should be structured in the
west because life is so easy yeah about
how America should fund by the way Pat
what was they do this sort of like
debate I don't know if it's in Cambridge
or in Oxford it's in the UK and they had
this comedian come on and basically sort
of clown wokeness constantly did you see
this yeah Constantine kissing he runs a
podcast okay yeah you've seen okay yes I
have I don't know if you can pull that
up Rob what a prime example of this
because he basically you talked about
like bowing to the idol of greenness
what what was the terminology you used
just like the green religion yeah the
green religion eco-fanatics and he said
let me tell you why
the the the the climate change and the
in the global uh catastrophe is Never
Gonna nobody's gonna work on it can you
go back to that Maslow's hierarchy of
needs and he basically said you have
literally billions of people
in all around the world India China
third world countries Africa you know
Middle East who are still on the bottom
level
who are still just fighting for air
water food shelter all that
and here you are at the top of the
pyramid
self-actualizing what a green new world
would be that's right because it's never
going to happen because you have
billions of people just fighting for the
basics the basics of survival meanwhile
you're over here basically on your you
know iPad in your air-conditioned home
in your college education and just sort
of looking down on people because they
they're they won't take climate change
as seriously as you when they're
literally fighting for their basic needs
in survival and that was the guys I
think I think his entire premise kissing
uh so I would I would sort of divide the
world into two parts one is the
developing or the underdeveloped world
and they are obviously not going to buy
into the whole decarbonization of the
economy wherever you stand on on fossil
fuels or Green Technology the fact is we
are going to use we are going to need
fossil fuels for many more years to come
because they are the cheapest and so the
people who are still very poor say most
of Africa occur most of Latin America
much of Asia these people are going to
be using those sorts of fuels more than
half the world
well over of the world
um and then and then the other part of
the world the the Western World
um also generally tends to be Democratic
and so what we are basically saying is
that
um we are asking
um or rather the greens are asking us to
democratically elect
for us to be poorer right and I think
that the much of the conflict in the
west right now has to do with the fact
that in order to implement the green
policies
all of us would have to suffer a great
decline in our standards of living and
that's what's playing out already in
places where the green agenda is most
advanced United Kingdom and Germany
um people are washing themselves in
lukewarm water because they cannot
afford hot water they cannot Heat their
homes in the middle of winter Europe is
much further ahead of where we are
heading if we embrace the same policies
the same green policies we are just
going to be much poorer or alternatively
we are going to elect governments that
are going to behave in a very different
fashion if you believe the future looks
bright order your future looks bright
hat today
foreign
[Music]